okay so let's talk about the amazing
spider-man I'll admit it's almost a
little pointless to talk about it seeing
how this came out like was it July
second or third and it's almost a week
later sorry about that I mean just
bummer views come out at some days
usually but I digress uh as usual the
best way to talk about a movie that's
part of kind of part of a franchise is
talking about what you thought the other
ones even though this is a reboot pport
counts again compare it to the original
spider-man films I might as well just
quickly say what I thought of those uh I
like them okay but I always sort of
acknowledge that they're silly can't be
even kind of dumb movies like I do like
them I mean don't get me wrong but I
guess when people were saying like oh
it's spider-man tooth one of the best
superhero movies ever and stuff I was
really you know in spider-man 1 is great
really spider-man 3 was too stupid that
was the one that was Tuesday so I mean I
by the time the third one came around I
was just used to the stupid so I just
went along with it me that's why it
doesn't bother me as much as other
people uh but I like them okay for just
sort of silly dumb fun you know with
some dramatic moments I mean give it
some credit uh but this was the one when
I heard they were gonna make a
spider-man movie but I heard Sam Raimi
was gonna do it uh this is sort of what
I thought I was gonna get I thought I
was gonna get this really adult more
dark more gritty a suspenseful dramatic
movie uh and that really is what this is
and I was really impressed by it I'm so
glad they finally went this angle
because I said the Tobey Maguire one
popcorn fun but that's really odd is um
and I'm really glad to see the really
diving into making these characters you
know relatable and likable these are
very likeable characters that cute well
the Garfield kid whatever I mean that I
don't usually say that kids that kids a
fucking star okay this kid is so likable
and he is so charismatic but he's not
like he's not like a Jonas Brother a
he's not like you
no constructed or anything he seems very
believable and he's a very likable and
everything that he does he's the he's a
little bit the oddball but not too far
he's pretty damn smart but not too
disgusting degrees you know where you
can't believe it you really buy it and
he really sells like does this great job
uh the girlfriend AG Wednesday thank
fucking god for this character and the
way she's written in the way she's acted
because you know man these other
spider-man movies I mean the women
aren't just idiots I mean I guess the
guys are kinda diat Stu but I mean it
really is just the you know they never
get pepper spray they never take some
martial arts and they never I mean they
really just sit around can look cute I
mean that's really about it this girl is
smart
okay I mean like there's a scene at the
end you know it's like the lizard man
he's gonna go he's gonna set off this
bomb or something like that she's like
okay I'll work out antidote and she like
goes and does it and there's another
scene where like the lizard breaks in a
looking for any find ring goes roar she
fucking gets like a hairspray cannon
like a zoom sets the fucker on fire just
thank you thank you god I'm so sick of
spider-man just going I'll save you
Oh in trouble again what a chakra you
know and just Oh God thank you for
making this chick actually have a
personality and likable and oh god okay
well I'll give me away too much is a guy
that the real reviews I don't give away
spoilers but at the end they're gonna do
something that seems very similar to
what they did in the first fighter man
movie with the boyfriend girlfriend uh
and yep I'm getting really pissed off
I'm like you're not you're fucking not
and then she just says one line and
literally I mean I just wanted to stand
up and say thank you Jesus God smart
characters I was just I'm sorry I really
fucking hate it a lot of characters in
the in the other spider-man movie cuz
they were just so they were just such
doofuses
and I think this movies really gonna
show just the faults of those other
films and even though they are sir just
whatever corny fun I mean it's like for
the people that were
like you know this is real gut-wrenching
drama and stuff like that I mean in all
the spider-man movies there's like maybe
two I think they were both in the second
one you know that we're like really sort
of heart-wrenching and stuff but I mean
like the actors in this movie really
sell it you know and the Martin Sheen is
great a Sally Field is great you know
the scientists blame blizzard is great
um so I I really really enjoyed this
movie I've really enjoyed the take they
were doing with this I'd have to say the
one thing that I did sort of miss from
it that this fireman movies the other
ones did have is that there was sort of
this sense of sort of like the the first
couple Superman movies or even the first
Batman movies it there was just sort of
this size to it and sort of this epic um
there is almost a simplicity to the
story that this is just a very basic
good versus evil but then there's these
little complications in there too so
it's it's going a little beyond that but
when you get to the climax you know it's
you know it's the showdown and you want
to see the showdown and you're hyped for
it if this didn't quite have that and
I'm not saying that it didn't come close
or that the action isn't fun it is great
action you know some great fight scenes
and everything but it's that is
something that the first one and even
bits of the second one did have that
they did have the simplicity to the
story that you could follow okay that
was very comic book is your very movie
ish you know like it so when you get to
the end you really want to see that
fight with this one with the villain I
mean you don't really feel like you know
yeah go kill spider-man go stop that
evil anything law that does they have to
do with the villain the villain is not
at first they make him very interesting
like he's this very user feel sorry for
him and ei seems kind of complex but as
soon as he starts turning into the
monster they don't really go that much
into is it a split personality is he
crazy what's his logic I mean it's very
rushed and I think that is a problem
because when you get to his big master
plan you're not entirely sure why he's
doing it I mean he says but you don't
really
the progression to how he got there or
even if he got there or if another part
of his mind got there a split
personality I mean you don't really know
um I hope it's not a split personality
because it's they've been to amend a
million times in these spider-man movies
um just make them bad all right I don't
know just something outside of a split
personality it just always seems to be
you blame whatever the Green Goblin or
the arms was that in spider-man 2 um you
know her venom and I digress again uh so
I really really enjoyed this film a lot
of it uh hinges sort of on the
performance of the main characters and
they they just do a great job I mean
this was such good casting and like I
said they're not they're not saying sir
these cookie cutter lines and they're
not just you know Peter smart so he's
gonna you know have the big glasses and
go droopy Derby I know all these
equations I know blah blah blah I mean
it's like he's really figuring shit out
and he's not a show-off and he's not
this big white I believe I mean he's you
really like this kid you and you like
this actor and you like the girl you
like you know the Margene's I feel all
those people so I was really really
impressed with this film and I'm glad we
finally got this movie now I won't make
clear I didn't read the spider-man
comics that much I read a little bit
growing up I didn't see you with my
brother so I don't know how accurately
you followed he was the big vitamin kid
growing up uh so I don't know how
closely it follows everything but I was
really impressed just as a movie what
they did um now the one other thing you
have to ask yourself I was asking myself
serve and advantage disadvantage is what
if the other movies didn't come out what
if this was the first fire demand movie
would it have played as well because I'm
thinking in the scene because there are
scenes that just are still part of the
origin like Uncle Ben getting shot and
so I don't think I'm giving anything
away with that but when you get there
it's sort of like okay well they this I
don't want to say it seems rushed but it
doesn't seem as slow as the other one I
mean the other one really sort of took
its time uh and I do sort of wonder if a
lot
that just has to deal the fact that oh
we've seen this we know what happens so
if you took the air aspire my movies out
with that so you've been effective
that's where what I've been trying to
figure out I think it's still work but
that would have been a little bit of an
issue and that is the one other problem
I have is that sometimes the editing in
the film it can be it not often but it
sometimes can be a tad Raj and it's
scenes can just really fly by when again
the others fireman we did sort of have
that slowing down since like a good
example is when Peter Parker's done Gwen
Stacy so you all see what I could do you
want me to show you the city or
something like then you think it's gonna
be this big romantic you know like can
you read my mind scene for Superman
we're swinging around with her and
you're seeing the city and in 3d and
IMAX it look great
one swing that's it that that was your
big romantic moment involving what's us
we or whatever uh so that kind of stuff
I saw a Miss I almost would have liked
some moments to be a little bit more
movie ish you know it may be that
something have taken a few you know a
little bit advice from the earth
spider-man's uh but again I think that
balls are the same category it's just
sort of that big grandness and that
simplicity that we can all identify with
but everything else like I said with the
people it's very identifiable and very
enjoyable
so my getting the people who would not
like this movie uh probably that really
like the original spider-man movies and
think there's nothing else there you
know or like the really sort of over the
top port rails you know and sort of like
the whatever like the sixties comic
books or something like that I mean this
seems more sort of like current or
current comic books you know where
they're served darker and edgier and try
with the subject matter trying to be a
little bit more realistic um so I say
people that like that probably wouldn't
like this one as much um yeah I mean
that that's where my take on it you know
and one other thing I'll say before I
sign off is that
some I remember uh Brian hi he does the
blasts angry gig videos uh of course
he's a big comic book guy he was saying
this big problem the originals fireman
says by the way it wasn't funny you know
he's supposed to be funny in the comics
he's supposed to be funny in the movies
why isn't he funny in the movies and
he's funny here and he's very enjoyable
and he creates this great personality
and it just reminded me a lot actually
when I saw Keaton as Batman I just
thought I really liked I want to see
more of this guy you know it's like he
has these troubles he tries to keep it
internal he's trying to keep it his own
problem you know but stuff catches up
and you just you really identify with
his pain and you really get in his skin
and he treats things in a very adult
manner outside of putting a property
Peter Parker on the back of his camera
that was dumb hell of a one dump thing
I'm like you're a genius get wide even I
digress okay so um I really enjoyed this
film I think people who would enjoy it
are people that want to see a darker
grittier uh wants a more likable because
maybe you like Tobey Maguire um but
certainly certainly sort of harsher more
as that like I says down to earth as the
subject matter can get you know being a
Spider Man and all so if you want to see
a film like that you'll probably like
this and there are some flaws I mean
don't get me wrong like you know with
with story and one or two you know
character traits like with the villain
but I think people will really like it I
think a lot of that comes from the
strength of the actors and the the
directing is very good too so guys
that's my two cents and I'll talk to you
later